we're asked to round 150 to 137 245 and
354 to the nearest 100 which is another
way of saying round each of these
numbers to the nearest multiple of 100
so let's think about them one by one so
let's draw a number line here and here
I'm counting up by hundreds these what
I've marked your hundred two hundred
three hundred four hundred these are all
multiples of 100 I could keep going up I
could go to five hundred six hundred so
on and so forth and let's start with 152
well where does 152 sit so it is halfway
in between is 150 152 is going to be
right to the right of that so that's 152
right over here so what are our two
options we might round up the multiple
of 100 above 152 is 200 the multiple of
100 below 152 is 100 so which direction
do we go in do we round up to 200 or we
around ground down to 100 well if we're
rounding to the nearest hundred if we're
rounding to the nearest hundred we want
to look at one place to the right of
that we want to look at the tens place
to decide which multiple of 100 is
closer to and the rules are very similar
to when we're round rounding to the
nearest tens place or really any place
we look one place to the right of it so
in this case we look at the tens place
and we say if this is 5 or larger we
round up and this is 5 or larger so
we're going to round up to 200 so this
we're going to round 152 we're going to
round to 200 which also makes sense 152
is a little bit closer to 200 it's 48
away from 200 than it is to 100 it's 52
away from 100 so it makes sense to go up
it will go up to the nearest multiple of
100 now let's think about 137 137 and I
encourage you to now pause the video and
try to round each of these other three
numbers to the nearest hundred well 137
is going to sit someplace going to sit
right over here 137 is going to be right
over there so two options we can round
down to 100 that's the mole
of 100 below 137 or we could round up we
could round up to 200
well 137 just looking at it is clearly
closer to 100 or we could apply our rule
if we're if we're rounding to the
nearest hundred we want to look at one
place to the right of that we want to
look at the tens place if this is five
or larger we round up if it's less than
5 we round down so in this case we would
round down to 100 let's do the same
thing with 245 if you haven't pause it
and try it yourself once again I want to
emphasize that'll make it really
valuable for you to try it on your own
so let's plot where 245 is so 245 is
right around this is 250 so 245 might be
right around here
so 245 and let's apply that rule if
we're trying to round to the nearest
hundred we would look to one place to
the right we'll look at the tens place
we can ignore the ones place we look at
the tens place here if it is greater
than or equal to 5 we round up if it is
less than 5 we round down so here we're
clearly going to round down and when we
round down we're going to round down to
the multiple of 100 that's below that's
directly below 245 well that's going to
be we're going to round down to 200 we
had two options if we rounded up we've
gone to 300 if we rounded down we would
go to 200 we're clearly closer to 200
and we can verify that with the rule the
tens place were in the 40s here the tens
places of four we're going to round down
now let's think about 354 354 if we were
to plot that this is 350 354 might be
right over here
354 so if we round it down we would go
to 300 if we round it up we'd go to 400
now let's apply a rule and let's also
think about it on the number line this
is all about finding the multiple of 100
that is closest to if you're trying to
round to the nearest hundred you want it
so you're on around to the nearest
hundred you want to look at the tens
place a place to the right of what of
the place you're rounding to if the tens
place is a five or larger you're going
to round
up this is a five are larger so we're
going to round up we're going to round
up to we're going to round up to 400 and
that also makes sense the rule is really
valuable if you're right at 350 right in
between then you would need the rule to
say hey let's look at this five and
round up but 354 is also closer to 400
than it is to 300 it's 54 away from 300
it's 46 away from 400 so it makes sense
that we would round up to 400